20 years ago this week astronomers
witnessed one of the brightest stellar
explosions in more than 400 years a
supernova that blazed with a power of
100 million Suns next on book TV
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson his
new collection is death by black hole
and other cosmic quandary this talk from
the Hayden Planetarium at the American
Museum of Natural History in New York
City is about an hour 45 minutes good
evening it's quite a wonderful showing
for this night so you might be wondering
who is this strange man standing in
front of you and I mean you know I look
exactly like Neil and so I might just
introduce myself as Neil deGrasse Tyson
no actually I am here to introduce him
he's an old friend of mine and I'm very
happy to have this pleasure and honor to
introduce this great man who is about to
show up here and my name is Ben
Oppenheimer and one of the
astrophysicists here at the Museum but I
thought about well how do you introduce
a man like this everybody has some
notion of who he is otherwise we
wouldn't have this show a showing like
this in the audience so I thought I
could go through all the ridiculous
things he's done in his life like going
to a substandard school up in Boston up
in Cambridge something called Harvard I
think it was I don't know these things
but he did decide ultimately to go to
Columbia for his PhD which was a
magnificent decision and in fact that's
where I met him 17 years ago when I was
an undergraduate and he was a graduate
student and I thought wow this guy is
really dynamic but he's kind of a
slacker and you know I wonder what he's
going to end up doing and please to joke
around a lot in variably led to my being
punched in the stomach at some point and
if I run out of here later it's because
I'm avoiding another one of those
punches so please excuse me but then
over the years I so I went off to
graduate school in California we lost
touch for a while got back in touch
1999 and I heard that he was putting
together this magnificent new
planetarium rebuilding the Hayden which
I had grown up going to of course and he
showed me around before it opened and
there was the certain Glee in his I just
utter pleasure and excitement of walking
around seeing these new exhibits
explaining some very complicated ideas
in modern astrophysics in a way that
hadn't been done before and I could tell
his passion was there this this was no
slacker at all and you can go and look
up all of his various accomplishments
there are many but I'll tell you this I
know of nobody any colleague or any even
acquaintances who has a dedication and
interest and passion for educating the
public about what we do in astrophysics
other than Neil Tyson and he's got a way
of saying things that I hope you enjoy
this evening so without further ado I
will introduce my great friend and
colleague Neil deGrasse Tyson
thank you all for coming out this
evening
I'm just told that there's a foot of
snow that just fell so we're stuck here
all night I'm most of the time that I'm
called upon to speak to the press it's
because there's some cosmic thing that
happened the universe flinched and here
at the American Museum of Natural
History we're not far from the major
news centers of the nation ABC CBS NBC
CNN is now just down the block and so
I'm actually a little uncomfortable
being in the media for something that is
fully just sort of marketed thing all
right I'm in the media now because there
are marketing people that put my face in
front of the camera to sell this book
this book for those on the TV screen oh
you might not have known we are being
taped to for later err on c-span this
evening so whatever you say can and will
be held against you so I guess my point
is I would say 85% of the time I get
approached by the press it is because
that I didn't twist their arm they
wanted a comment on something that
happened in the universe and that level
of public curiosity and appetite for the
cosmos I don't take lightly neither do
any of my colleagues we see it as a
genuine measure of the public's
fascination and appreciation for all we
do in the professional astrophysics
community and in case you want to know
how many of us there are there's about
six thousand five hundred six and a half
thousand astrophysicists in the world
and if you remember your population
numbers for the world that number is
about six and a half billion so you
divide those two numbers you get one in
a million so here's here's the catch if
you're ever in the company of an
astrophysicist that's the time to
ask your questions because you never
know when the next time will be where
you'll be around another astrophysicist
okay but it's not that many people who
are responsible for bringing all these
riches of the universe to you and we are
tickled to death every time the public
shows interest if not for the Hubble
telescope for you know discovery of a
black hole in the center of the galaxy
right on down to the discoveries of the
space program so I want to publicly
thank all of you and the rest of what
makes up the general public for your
support for what we do over all these
years and what I expect to continue into
the future I want to make sure there's
plenty of time for Q&A at the end it's
my favorite part of a program and so and
I'm not going to read from the book
because you just buy the book and read
the book you don't need me to do that so
what I want to do is I first tell you
about it and then sort of pluck subjects
from it and then reflect on those
subjects and I'll do that for most of
the hour and then we'll break and take
Q&A that's the that's the layout for the
evening the book is called death by
black hole of course I was told that
c-span has that that one camera and so
you put this here then it's just always
in view you know of the camera I learned
that from Andy Rooney some years back he
just took his book and just put it there
and just and went had a cup of coffee
you know though they had to keep showing
it you know I started writing for
Natural History Magazine as a columnist
in 1995 the then editor had heard me on
the radio and felt that they needed some
contributions from the universe to
bookend the magazine with the
contribution that they were getting
monthly from Stephen Jay Gould and so I
said sure sounds like fun and so I began
in January 1995 not knowing that every
month writing an essay at least for me
would be like giving birth
now the women are saying you have no
clue what giving birth is okay I confess
I have no clue about giving birth
however each of these essays is sort of
the sum each essay that forms a chapter
in this book twelve years hand-picked
essays that have appeared in Natural
History Magazine selected and called and
organized for this volume each month
that I wrote an essay it was it was the
sum of what I knew in astrophysics all
that I knew as an educator and all that
I could bring together to make it real
and to pump that out each month it was
like my flesh was getting hewn from my
body and put down onto the page and I
felt like after each month I had to
regrow part of my body cells okay that's
why I can all I can think of is like it
was giving birth and so no it's not easy
to do that it's hard to do that but it
is one of the greatest pleasures of my
life because I get to think about what
words to use what phrases what what
words work together either poetically
scientifically rhythmically and so it's
my hope that you could pick up this book
open to any page and land on a paragraph
in that page and you feel good reading
read in that paragraph okay that's my
goal now whether I achieve that goal I
don't know but that's the goal and so
these chapters are some of what I feel
were my best as well as chapters that I
didn't necessarily feel my best but were
highly requested on my website and by
other means of communication highly
requested by the public
so we're organized in sections and I'm
just going to pluck something from each
section first section the nature of
knowledge Oh later on with is a part my
favorite section is when the universe
turns bad all the ways the cosmos wants
to kill us and in there's the title
chapter death by black hole but there's
also a chapter on on killer Astrid
it's been a full discussion of one
that's actually headed our way if we
have time I'll get to that just remind
me if you we can fit that in but just if
there's time I don't want you know just
if it fits in in the session that we
have together remind me to tell you
about the asteroid that will render the
entire west coast of the United States
unlivable so let me lead off there's a
section here called the nature of
knowledge and there's an essay there
that was smooth that works that one work
hardly ever works but it worked now four
seas will do anything for a c-span here
there's a there's a chapter called
coming to your senses and I want to just
sort of share with you where I'm trying
to go there we all know the human body
has senses how many five some people
claim they have a sixth sense get to
that in a moment
but the five we know and love a sight
hearing touch taste and smell thank you
a couple of these are not very useful
when you're studying the universe like
taste you know your tongue doesn't reach
the cosmos so the tongue is not very
useful neither is your sense of touch
abut sight is certainly very useful no
doubt about it
and nursing a chest cold from a few
weeks ago so forgive me we got our five
senses and then you some people say they
have a sixth sense they can know things
that your five senses can't and you say
well what might that be that can maybe
feel like they know the future or they
know when someone's looking at them or
they know they feel it somehow turns out
turns out anytime you bring that person
into a controlled laboratory those
talents just go away they just don't
exist they're missing in the laboratory
so either it is an actual talent that
just somehow hates laboratories or
there's sort of a delusional thing where
you think you have the power but in fact
you don't and you're remembering the
hits and not the misses
you pick up the phone he said Graham I
knew that I knew that was going to be
you okay well if it wasn't her
you wouldn't say oh I thought this was
going to be my grave you just don't even
say that
because they can kind of look bad and so
you forget the missus you remember the
hits and you this is self-selection go
psychologists have known about this
forever if it's we do power selves into
thinking we are more powerful and more
brilliant and deeper and more insightful
than we actually are
maybe it's an ego preserving feature of
what it is to be human but by the time
this our session together is over I hope
to disavow you of those great feelings
you might have of ourselves as a species
so it turns out in science we have
dozens of senses there's plenty of
things you might want to know about but
you can't because you're limited to your
five senses for example right now you
have no clue and no way to measure
without a device what is the level of
the magnetic field in this room no clue
if you could measure magnetic field you
could think of that as another sense
measure the magnetic fields around you
we have no idea we are not equipped for
that neither can we measure for example
the presence of ionizing radiation well
you would eventually know this because
like your limbs would fall off and you
say hey something happen okay
you'd be sterile all that be take a
little longer to figure out you know you
we have no capacity to measure this
other things you don't open other things
you don't know there's some obscure
things like polarization you can't
detect the polarization of light and
that light has vibrates in two different
directions and you can polarize it so it
only vibrates in one direction you can
devise glasses that can polarize light
but you still Gordon know the difference
you don't know we have it's a big deal
in in astrophysics whether light is
polarized or not that tells us where
light is coming from and what its points
of origins are but another sort of
everyday thing you just can't figure out
one of the
is you can't detect low-level earth
tremors why because you have like the
shock absorbers in your knees and so
your knees sort of get rid of it
you have filters against it but you put
up a seismograph there it is there it is
so so we I go on and on and on and on
and on perhaps the most important sense
we don't have is the ability to see
outside of the spectrum of visible light
you know visible light ROYGBIV red
orange yellow green blue indigo indigo
violet you a bit there beat ivy now
where the indigo come from Isaac Newton
who first labeled the colors of the
spectrum had this mystical fascination
with the numeral seven the number set
and so when he went to label the colors
of the spectrum and got six he said we
need seven somewhere in there so there
is indigo you got it was stuck with
indigo now if you have enough precision
to put an indigo to ten other colors we
could have given you in this full
continuum of spectra light any color
sensitive people couldn't rattle off
thirty colors in there but no we got
seven and Roy G bill was born okay even
go beyond the VIII beyond VIII you get
what all true violet we can't we have no
way to detect ultraviolet I said it's
not completely true you can detect it in
a time-delay sense okay so depending on
what shade of skin color you have you go
out to the beach and lay under the Sun
if you are not protected you're laying
there damn fine
and then how many hours later you look
like a lobster okay so there's a delay
there it's the ultraviolet that made you
look like a lobster but you didn't know
it at the time at the time so by the
time you figured it out it was too late
let's go to the other side of red you
get infrared can't see that either you
can we do have infrared sensors we sense
infrared in the form of heat that's what
we
all heat when we feel infrared but
beyond infrared there's microwaves we
have no microwave detector well now we
do cuz we all carry around cellphones
these are microwave detectors but if we
were if eyes of our eyes were sensitive
to microwaves tune it in tune in the
microwave all your cell phones would be
ablaze with light ok we'd all be walking
down the street you know and you'd know
who was on how to phonecall and who
didn't ok if we have microwave detectors
then microwave towers would be ablaze in
broad daylight and in the middle of the
night we have no such detectors radio
waves we can't detect radio waves x-rays
gamma rays this is the full sweep of the
electromagnetic spectrum and in
astrophysics we have telescopes and
detectors in each one of these bands far
beyond what your naked eye can detect
and so every day every night of every
day the astrophysicist
is invoking a full suite of senses that
brings us that much closer to the
universe because if you only observe the
night sky with a visible light telescope
expressions of our own eyeballs you'd be
missing
what black holes are doing in their
environment they're dining there flying
stars
the outer gas layers of stars as it
descends spirals and descends down to
this abyss it radiates ultraviolet and
x-rays so the first x-ray telescope the
first x-ray telescope the first thing it
discovered in the universe was a black
hole candidate SCOE x1 Scorpius x1 then
there's another one in the constellation
Cygnus called Cygnus x1
these were sources of x-rays we were
previously blind - turns out black hole
right there black hole so you can't
claim to know the universe unless you
look in as many different ways as invoke
as many different senses as you possibly
can
now there's a point to all of this the
point is until about the turn of the
century not our century but the 1800s to
the 1900s until then
it was possible to say to do an
experiment and say to yourself that
makes sense or that doesn't make sense
and you had a good chance of being
accurate in your Assessor come to 20th
century with telescopes started getting
seriously big where atom smashers
started breaking apart atoms probing
nature on levels and on scales never
previously accessible to our senses now
what does it mean for something to make
sense for something to make sense what
that means is I take if I take this
bottle of water and I let go of it what
will happen to it it will fall in fact
so linked is my act of letting go to the
fact of this falling in our minds that
all you have to do is say to me drop it
and that means let go but suppose you
lived in a world where 30% of the time
when you let go this went and floated to
the ceiling 30% of the time it's only
70% of the time I felt well then common
sense would mean something different
under those conditions what was common
is 30% of the time the thing floats up
so the word drop wouldn't even exist
someone gasped over in the corner here
it would be let go and let's see what
happens you know people be taking bets
you know people bet on all kinds of
things so what happens is we break the
atom get inside get into the nucleus and
a whole new world of physics opens up to
us world of quantum mechanics where the
laws are different we discovered we
Edwin Hubble discovers that our our
galaxy is not alone among galaxies in
the universe a great discovery of the
1920s going on simultaneously while
quantum mechanics was being discovered
the science of the small and not only
that he discovers that the galaxies are
hurtling away from each other he
discovers the
universe a few years later the big bang
theory of the universe advances with not
much data but that we're expanding at
the time you turn the clock back you
find out the whole universe sometime in
the past all occupied the same volume at
the same time you say that doesn't make
sense how could the whole universe fit
on the head of a pin that doesn't make
sense and then you realize the universe
doesn't care about your senses because
we are probing it beyond the range that
your senses were formulated your our
senses emerge from being born ordinary
human being in this world breathing air
walking in one jeez worth of gravity
that is our life and so in modern
science we no longer require that a
successful idea makes sense and I think
that's created quite a bit of confusion
when a scientist says oh well the whole
universe was this and a particle pops
out of existence here and shows up there
and there's 11 dimensions and this and
you're here to say is he what's he
smoking you know you wonder what's going
on with the scientists today and the
fact is our regime is no longer grounded
in the limitations of the five senses we
carry with us and so the lesson there
and which comes across in that chapter
is my goal is that it before you
celebrate the brilliance of our five
senses think about what it is you're not
seeing about the universe and then ask
yourself what do you need to know about
that in order to claim that you know the
universe to begin with that's coming to
your sense
another on the knowledge of nature I'll
talk about the vagabonds of the solar
system in there there's like Pluto shows
up but I don't unload oh okay so let's
leave Pluto alone for a night I think
it's you know it's got to get over
having been blue toad you know that was
the word of the year did you see that to
be Pluto Pluto
so was Pluto Pluto or it was Pluto
something else which had to happen and
then everything else is Pluto after
they're after
I'm just we got to get top linguist on
this all right get a full report on that
in the morning so I believe will slip by
that one I'm okay you're okay with that
I'm okay with that I gotta hit
Goldilocks here we are in section for
the meaning of life the challenges and
triumphs of knowing how we got here we
got to check little Goldilocks and the
three planets you remember Goldilocks we
all know Goldy yeah we all know gold you
know gold Goldilocks
now here's my problem with the
Goldilocks story okay and say hey I got
a problem because if I were the parent
and I found Goldilocks in the house
I just eat Goldilocks okay that's what
would happen right that'd be the end of
the story and the lesson is don't go
bustin in other people's houses okay
what you want a lesson there's a lesson
all right but they want their lesson to
be a little more nuanced so one part is
too hot too cold one is just right well
in the solar system
you can be a distance from the host star
that might be too close for water to be
sustained as a liquid if so all the
water on your planet will evaporate not
available to you to make life because
life as we know it requires liquid water
so now if you can go a little farther
away whatever water you might have
you're too far from the Sun the
intensity of the sun's energy is too low
the water freezes once again not
available for your circulatory system
and so you imagine that beyond a certain
distance you would not find planets with
water northern planets with life so
there'd be this comfortable Goldilocks
zone the habitable zone where you'd find
liquid water prevalent on the surface of
a planet fine fine
turns out you can go outside the zone
and find water but I'll get to that
later but right now let's just consider
that scenario now turns out other things
affect this like greenhouse gases that
trap heat and other and what it would
air pressure where if the pressures too
low you can't have liquid water the
water just go straight from ice to gas
you've seen this before it happens
it happens with dry ice did they still
have the ice cream man in the park and
he opens up the thing is dry ice and
then it frozen carbon dioxide you've
never seen liquid carbon dioxide because
the air pressure on Earth is too low for
it to ever reach in liquid it goes
straight from solid to gas we have a
word for that's called sublime kind of
like that word sublime for such a an odd
chemical phenomenon and so so fine so
we're here on earth and say we're fine
we've got room temperature I'm good with
that and then you look a little to the
left
you get Venus our sister planet it's
about the same size as we are about the
same mass as we are a lot of the same
structural features that we have it's
just a little closer to the Sun than we
are if we are one unit of distance from
the Sun Venus is 0.7 so Venus is 70
and of the way to us from the Sun so you
say okay Venus where are you just like
earth no Venus its atmospheres nearly
100 times as thick as our atmosphere
that's bad enough because you'll get
just get crushed but you'll be lucky if
that's all that happened to you
because the temperature on Venus in
having a carbon dioxide atmosphere it
has a runaway greenhouse effect it is
900 degrees fahrenheit on the surface of
Venus 900 degrees and I did the math you
could take a 16-inch pizza put it out on
the windowsill and it will cook in 9
seconds u2 you would have been vaporized
in the process but you'll have a cook
pizza that's just right in 9 seconds ok
of course venus is the goddess of love
and beauty and as 900 degrees they
didn't know that when they named the
planet now let's go a little to the
right
a little bit farther from the Sun than
we are we get planet Mars Mars has
riverbeds that meander flood plains
river deltas lake beds but not a single
drop of water at all but these features
were made by water we are 99% confident
of that assertion that's what water does
when it flows in abundance it makes
rivers and lakes and valleys and river
deltas you can do a comparative
geography of earth features and Mars
features and one-for-one you now all of
them we had the water go nobody knows we
think it's sunk down below the surface
froze there in a kind of permafrost
situation but there's none on the
surface some knobs got turned on Venus
and on Mars to turn them into what we
would consider completely inhospitable
environments Venus is 900 degrees
Fahrenheit Mars is 250 degrees below
zero
bone-dry mark it's right there it's
right there
Juneau Mars among all the planets is the
most hospitable place there is after
Earth yet it'll kill you posthaste
so the lesson there for me is we know
Mars once had water and it does not why
not let's find out why because if we
find out which knob had turned in the
ecosystem of Mars I want to know if
we're turning that same knob here on
earth we don't know that you got people
saying why are we studying the universe
we don't need worry about earth problems
here and I'm thinking about how about
that asteroid coming in you're not
looking up for that one you worried
about the budget in Congress and this we
got an asteroid coming we got a planet
has a runaway greenhouse a planet that
used to have water and does not excuse
me where do you think answers are going
to come from we're not an I'll it comes
from the sky thank you answer is going
to come from the sky but not some Island
we are participant in the cosmos
vulnerable to cosmic phenomena not only
that there's cosmic phenomena that would
give us insight into who and what we are
and if we don't have that urge you just
move back into the cave
because that's where we'd all be if we
didn't have some fraction of us out
there trying to push that frontier it
wouldn't have to be a cosmic for just
any frontier well wonder what's on the
other side of the cliff
that person doesn't come back so that's
fine what's on the other side of the
valley it's a cliff it's I meant to say
Mountain there I'm sorry I didn't mean
me other side of the cliff
let's start that again so they say
what's on the other side of the mountain
and so they go and find out they bring
back fruits or riches or whatever
whatever that's what exploration is
that's what it is to be human so why we
have a space program so we have the
luxury of having a space program so so I
don't know the universe I see that's
that's that's that's the ticket right
there that's where insights will come
about where we fit in this universe I'm
gonna go on to a radio bubble part of
the section on the meaning of life a
radio bell you might have not heard that
phrase before I don't know a radio
bubble a radio bubble you might say how
do you if they're aliens out there that
are intelligent how would you tell them
that you're here do send a spaceship our
fastest spaceships ever launched would
take seventy five thousand fifty
thousand years to reach the nearest star
that's slow and there's a rule in
science if you do an experiment you want
to be alive when the experiment is done
it's they don't tell you that in
graduate school but you figure that out
empirically okay so sending a probe to
another planet I don't think so not
unless we might develop warp drives or
something okay and that could happen but
I don't think anytime soon or any time
that we should be banking on so what do
you do well you can send light
how about radio waves that's why it a
form of light radio waves we have big
radio telescopes just reverse them send
us a signal out the other way it will
travel at the speed of light printed
86,000 my
as per second still takes a while
there's nothing closed out there nothing
the nearest star to the Sun is four
years away traveling at the speed of
light so it still takes a while but you
can outlive that one all right
so you do this and you say well wait a
minute maybe we have a head start on
this plan let's look back in time how
long have we been radio-loud
how long have we been producing radio
signals on earth some of which will have
leaked away from Earth you just go back
in time
turns out TV waves the frequency that we
use to communicate with television those
go straight if they don't hit you they
go didn't they're gone they leave the
atmosphere that's why you don't like in
the old days remember when TVs had
antennas remember that yeah you're all
20 and under I know right there was a
day long ago we had to get out of your
sofa to change the channel of the
television set
and while you did that you had to adjust
the antenna until it was just right but
then you'd be in the way of the screen
then you'd let go and then the image
would go bad again so everyone would
then tell you to stand there holding the
antenna this was many moons ago people
used to live this way it's true I'm just
thinking people sit they can sit in a
couch honey where's the remote you know
and I like spend 10 minutes looking for
the remote rather than just going up to
the TV to change the channel anyhow back
when TV was broadcast which it still is
but most of people get it via cable
today a TV way to go straight out and so
too would a shortwave radio would go
well it depends on which wavelength we
use some would reflect off the
ionosphere of the earth and stay sort of
trap others would escape but if you if
you take the inventory of what these
programmes were you can say
hey we have this growing sphere of
influence in the galaxy beginning with
our earliest broadcast they've been
going now for 70 years
so in fact we are in the middle of our
own radio bubble that has a radius of 70
light-years it's a radius that is washed
over all the stars that fill that volume
hundreds of stars and so we've already
announced ourselves to aliens if they're
there and want to listen so the earliest
of these programs it would be it so the
aliens are listening right they get the
feeble signal but then but they're alien
to smart aliens so they can figure it
out
recode the carrier signal to the main
thing we can get the image and there's
howdy-doody okay
and then they see listen interesting
species let me figure out how the male
and the female interact with one another
and they learn that from early episodes
of I Love Lucy yes these are benchmark
ways that men and women interact and
then as the radio wave continues to wash
over then they have episodes of Gomer
pile you know and you think about this
this is our first introduction to the
aliens this is kind of scary now there's
some programs that they would never get
programs that have only ever been
broadcast over cable like MTV's beavis
and butt-head okay so there's certain
things that are good that you that
that's not the first thing the aliens
get so some programming is forever
hidden in the electrons of your care of
your coaxial cable so so you look at
this and you say what will they think of
us you know then they get broadcast that
there was like atomic bomb and a hundred
thousand war and I am certain that these
aliens who are in desperate search
themselves for intelligent life in the
universe they will conclude that earth
does not contain intelligent life
and pass us by um how am i doing on time
here we okay I got a few more things are
we okay you like you you call everybody
got like be somewhere after this I just
want to make sure that we okay I don't
want to mess up your your plans for
later
where we going so when the universe
turns bad well that's that contains the
title chapter death by black hole now to
get in trouble with a black hole you got
to go out and find him there aren't that
many of them in the galaxy so you're
looking for trouble if you die for
having fallen into a black hole I'm just
letting you know that now but if I had
my choice that's how I would die because
it is so cool all right no you can say
well dr. cycle you'd like to sort of die
in this hospital bed in this Hospice
that's they call in hospices right I say
no launch me to the black hole right
over there in the gamma sector all right
that's how I'm going to do it so here's
what happens you stand up here on earth
and again six something and my feet are
closer to the center of the earth then
the top of my head is you can do the
math and you can calculate that the
force of gravity between earth and you
is stronger at your feet than it is at
your head because your feet are closer
to the center of the earth it's simple
Newtonian gravity but you don't feel
that difference I don't blame being
lightheaded on this fact all right if
that's not what May whatever you is not
this so here you are and you don't
notice it because your body overcomes it
it's not it's barely measurable and why
is it barely measurable because you are
tiny I am tiny compared with the size of
the earth this is eight thousand miles
in diameter well going to the Senate
four thousand miles to the Senate and
I'm the six feet standing on top of it
that's nothing a black hole however
because it's so small you can get much
closer to it compared with your height
and so what happens is you descend to
this and your feet lead it so imagine a
feet first dive to the black hole and so
you start getting pulled and and you
begin to stretch and it kind of feels
good you know we all like what you do
when you wake up in the morning you
stretch people pay top dollar to get to
stretch but I think all the yoga people
do this direction okay and it feels good
until you realize it's not stopping and
it's okay I'm not having fun anymore and
by the way this difference in gravity is
called the tidal force it's the same
kind of forcing that creates the tides
on earth why the water stretches across
Earth's surface so as you get pulled you
begin to feel it and there is a point
where the difference in gravity between
your head and your toe becomes greater
than the molecular bonds of your flesh
and at that moment your body snaps into
two pieces and then those two pieces
continue to descend and they feel this
difference in gravity and then they snap
into two pieces each now we went from
one to two we're now up to four cadet we
got someone to the front row was
plugging his ears you don't want to hear
about getting snapped into two pieces
and this continued one to two to four to
eight to 16 to 32 you keep this up
you're not much of anything after a
short while you're just the stream of
particles descending down now it turns
out that's not even the worst thing to
happen to you
it gets worse because in a black hole
the vicinity around of this fabric of
space and time in the vicinity of a
black hole funnels you it narrows as it
comes near the black hole this is what
we learned from Einstein's general
relativity it describes the shape of
space in the presence of gravity
and you do up the math you find out that
at a black hole space funnels down to
the point so as you descend the black
hole you are not only stretched you're
not only stretched you are extruded
through the fabric of and you you move
through the fabric of space and time
like toothpaste through a tube and we
have a word for this go
spaghettification that's cool that
there's a word for dying while falling
into a black hole spaghettification I
don't know if it's fusilli again I don't
know whatever but it's you know number
two spaghetti number eight whatever that
is any pasta fiction Otto's here angel
hair angel hair pasta that's the
thinnest of them if I remember correctly
because they measured the thickness of
angels hair to determine this so you
want to avoid black holes if either they
tear up the environment we got a big one
in the center of the Milky Way galaxy
although it's not the biggest in the
neighborhood this the Andromeda galaxy
our nearest big neighbor it's gotten one
the dwarfs our black hole okay and some
astrophysicists have like black hole
Envy you know it's like welcome ours
isn't as big as that because there's
like cool stuff happening in the middle
of the andromeda galaxy because it's got
a bigger black hole that we got some
cool stuff but there's a cooler all
right and we what we learned is that
most galaxies indeed have black holes in
their centers in their centers and send
the properties of so many galaxies
previously imagined to be distinct and
separate and classified as distinct
objects turns out it's just a matter of
what angle we were viewing the
turbulence created by the black hole in
the center so there's been a tremendous
coming together of galactic information
just over the past ten or fifteen years
simply because you're looking at a
galaxy from a different way and so black
holes you really simply just want to
avoid them
I got a chapter in here which I think is
my section here which i think is my
favorite it's when science meets culture
in fact if you're a little science
phobic which is probably not true if you
even knew how to get into this museum
and come to this room but maybe you were
dragged here by a friend raise your hand
if you were dragged here by a friend
tonight
we've got somebody in the back row
another one here brave of you sir to be
direct to agree on your you know on your
Tuesday night to come here thank you for
coming that that section is an
exploration of what happens when science
meets culture and I want to highlight a
couple of items in it I've got fear of
numbers this one is kind of fun it's you
look around you going to elevator this
is the first indication that we are
number phobic okay so you got the
numbers and then you get to the lobby so
if you count them down 806 or 32 and
it's not a 1 but it's an L that's the
lobby but then they're always floors
below the lobby and then there's like ll
and B and then B B and then s B and I'm
thinking what are you doing here just
call it zero negative one negative two
negative oh no siree no negatives in
this culture any accountants out there
no negatives on your balance sheet you
put your negative numbers in parenthesis
are you afraid of your negatives raise
me if you're not counting here weight
weighs your hand accounting right there
why do you what what what's good with
you in the negative numbers sir please I
got a no he doesn't know either he's a
hundred ah look you'll get back to me on
this one okay it's in parenthesis I was
in a hotel in Geneva Switzerland
they had negative numbers and their
hotel you went to zero negative one
negative two negative three and then I
realized of course Switzerland that's
where the world's largest particle
accelerator is located people they're
not afraid of numbers so they can put
negative numbers in their hotels another
thing take a walk up and down Broadway
right here in Manhattan in New York City
and go poke your head into each elevator
Bank and you will find out that 75% of
them I did this experiment do not have a
number 13
check it have you seen this look next
time and I'm thinking this is not 21st
century America I'm gonna go next time
I'm gonna go on uh I'm gonna get a
sharpie and cross out to number 14 and
put 13 next to it I cuz they holy you're
foolin that's the thirteenth floor she
had people are afraid of the number 13
if people afraid of numbers what hope do
we have in this world this is scary just
afraid of a number you know about the
lottery the state lottery okay it's
widely said that that's a tax on the
poor because people with lower income
spend a disproportionately higher
fraction of that income on the lottery
and if you look at the data on the line
your chance for any one in five million
or something and I'm thinking to myself
no it's not a tax on the poor the
lotteries attacks on everyone who never
did well in mathematics in school that's
what it's a tax up and you don't have to
do that well in math to figure out
that's not what to do with your money
man guess me angry I got to calm down
wait let me get a drink
all right where was I
let me Adam okay I got another one one
of my most highly requested essays it's
called Hollywood nights this one I'm
going to apologize in advance yes on
occasion I'm one of those if you bring
me to the movie theater I'm going to say
that's the wrong sky that they just put
the moon that's the wrong moon and I'll
be annoying as I sit next to you but
only on selected films if the film has
no pretense of getting any facts
straight at all then I don't even give
it the - I don't even I might even still
enjoy the movie but I'm not going to
worry about it but there's some films
that had no excuse at the top of that
list its Titanic we know what day it
sank what month it sank what year it's
saying what longitude what latitude we
know everything about that night so why
is it that that Kate Winslet after the
ship sank there she is on that on that
wooden plank
okay fine late why didn't lean on the
Caprio try to climb on there with her
why what what why not least experiment
it just clings on it's okay I'll just
die here I'm fine
I'm okay with that it's like what we'll
find another plank there's got to be
some other floating stuff out there
where was I I was Kate Winslet so there
she is and she's whistling or whisk in
delirium and she's looking straight up
there is only one sky she should have
seen and the sky that the camera showed
you was the wrong sky not only that the
left side of the
sky was a mirror reflection of the right
side of the sky it was not only wrong
it was lazy and here's a film that was
widely advertised as having the cook
that they sent a submersible Jim Cameron
sent a submersible down to the Titanic
and looked at the wall sconces and the
china patterns and all the designs of
the staterooms and got every rivet every
design perfect on his ship for his movie
now you can't double check any of that
because you don't have a submersible but
for 50 bucks
you can buy a planetarium program to
tell you what the sky looked like the
night that Titanic sank so I was pissed
so I made a letter I came I rushed back
to my office got my finest of letterhead
I got a letterhead and got every all
5-color live astrophysicist but I got
everything on that let the director
Frederick P Rose director that I got all
that and I wrote the letter no reply I
said I try I did do I did due diligence
there a couple of years later I bump
into Jim Cameron in Washington that's he
not this time
I bumped him in in Pasadena California
there's a NASA meeting out there but he
was very active with NASA and he's and
he's an explorer he's a genuine Explorer
on top of his other formidable talent as
a movie producer and director so he's
there and I said you know gee I sent you
a letter a couple years those mr.
Cameron since your letter a couple of
years ago about this and the sky and it
wasn't Ryan and I was kind of alright
and he said well actually that happened
in post-production so and he missed that
one so I was still angry I don't know I
was not a good another hits it for me
but al is the answer I he missed that
one fine so two years let after that no
what are we up to this happened 80 no no
sorry now we're up to 2003 just a couple
of years ago he was honored by Wired
magazine with a big party here at the
Rose Center for Earth and space and just
cuz like if my place I got invited to
sort of hang out and they invited me to
dinner there's like eight of us he and
some of his closest friends and we're
there he's with his friends
the wine is pouring
I said here's my big chance to do it
again okay now I'm just being like
immature at this point so I said Jim
because now I can call him Jim we're
drinking wine you call him Jim
so I said Jim a couple of years ago I
told you about the sky and I'm still
kind of wondering why didn't you think
why why why what and so he said Ruth let
me think this one hmm
last I checked Titanic has grossed about
a billion dollars worldwide imagine how
much more it would have grossed if I had
the sky correct can I make a bigger fool
of myself in front of so then I just let
that one go I didn't I was done until
two months later I get a phone call from
some guy and he says hi I'm Johnny Jones
I forgot the guy's name but he I did
yeah Johnny everybody who I forget it's
just Johnny Jones so he co says I'm I'm
working in post-production for a reissue
with the director's cut of the Titanic
and Jim Cameron tells me you have a sky
for me to use for the new footage
now he couldn't change all the skies the
ones that were already sort of built in
but the new footage had the new sky so
it is possible it is that it is hope in
the world and while I make I make fun of
Jim and he the fact is he's he's a he's
a man of high integrity with regard to
what he produces and what he cares about
and so I just wanted to tip my hat to
him in that episode and for politely
putting me in my place without actually
just telling me that I was a you know
what he really wanted to surely have
told me um I got one more and then we'll
just go to Q&A how's that we okay we're
okay
is it temperature all right out there
yeah I'm okay up here too
so I'm glad I'm glad um
the final section is it's called science
and God when ways of knowing collide and
that section contains my most highly
downloaded essay ever written relatively
recently it's called the perimeter of
ignorance and I want to share with you
some of the themes of that essay before
we go to QA um I wrote that essay at a
time when the intelligent design
movement was garnering headlines weekly
and intelligent design movement in case
you had forgotten or never knew or
weren't paying attention but you're
you're a newspaper reading crowd so I'm
sure you were all there
insulting design is the assertion that
there are things about nature that are
so intricate so sort of brilliant and
concept that it just couldn't happen and
so defying of the methods and tools of
science to decode that it must have had
the hand
of an intelligent designer an
intelligent in that reference refers to
something vastly more intelligent than
our feeble human minds and so that's the
premise and so you go around look
through nature up that's one of those
that's intelligently designed that's an
intelligent now it's hard to separate
the invocation of the word intelligent
in that sentence with a reference to
some somebody's God so you have to ask
is this a religious movement or is it a
movement of some pure philosophy
untouched by religion you have to ask
that
and the courts ask that of the movement
and their famous court case in Dover
Pennsylvania November just just last
November where the school district tried
to bring intelligent design into the
science classroom as a science plan as
part of the science curriculum and the
judge read the evidence for and against
intelligent design and basically through
the court case out they threw it out
wrote one hundred and one hundred thirty
five hundred fifty page statement about
why science to do science you need data
and evidence and discovery and this sort
of thing and a telogen design didn't
fulfill that so here is this debate
going on and I'm normally I will jump
into debates unless I think I have
something unique to contribute if you
had a lot of voices I'm okay go do it
let me find something that needs voices
okay that one didn't really need my
voice there plenty of people arguing but
then I thought wait a minute it's
missing something I've got to address
and you know what it's missing
intelligent design
that's the food that's what you call it
today but as an idea it's been around
for thousands of years in AD 150
Claudius Ptolemy one of the architects
of the geocentric universe earth in the
middle it was having to be a wrong model
but it was brilliantly wrong and of
course people to think about what's
going on in the mo
missions of the objects of the night sky
when he looked up he'd see the planets
move this is pre Newton of course you
see the planets move and then they slow
down and stop and then go backwards and
then slow down stop and then continue
forward again nobody understood this
there's like a mystery
so Ptolemy would look up and he penned
these words in the manuscript of his
greatest work he said when I trace at my
pleasure the windings to and fro of the
heavenly bodies the planets in that case
I no longer touch earth with my feet I
stand in the presence of Zeus himself
and take my fill of ambrosia now that's
beautiful
theories basking in the majesty of his
god Zeus almost in celebration of his
ignorance I don't know what this is but
surely somebody does
that's Zeus and I'm here with it so
that's a form of intelligent design he
looks at something he can't figure out
his tools available to him do nothing
for him so he says Zeus did it let's
move for going to leave some people out
but they're more of the same examples
the essay has them all let me fast
forward to Isaac Newton we're not going
forward 1700 years
1600 years go fast what to Isaac Newton
Isaac Newton's my man I think is the
smartest person to ever walk this earth
and I'm not alone in that assessment now
if you want to fight me on that we can
do that I'll give you just one example
and then they'll just just to sort of
temper you if you're ready to go to
fisticuffs because like Einsteins your
man or Leonardo or whomever I'm going to
set you straight okay Isaac Newton
discovers well first he's got to put the
Indigo in there I get that gets that out
of the way
then alright actually did that second
but he discovered the laws of motion and
the laws of gravity and someone comes up
to it says uh Ike I don't know if he
went by Ike but sounds better
Ike why do planets orbit in the shape of
ellipses and not some other shape any
lips as a kind of squash circle so he
looks they say you know because by the
way his his equations of gravity give
you ellipses and so but he thing he said
well you know I don't know I'll get back
to you so he goes back home to his home
in Lincolnshire which is out away
tripple suburbs of London I Newton was
avoiding the plank that was running
through London killing many many people
he left London Newton was smart okay he
left London
people are dying you leave okay first
indication of how smart the man is he
left London went to a hillside at home
in Lincolnshire goes back
I forgot how long this took but it
wasn't very long it was you count it in
months not in years she goes back
figures out why his planets go any lips
is and he comes back I figured out
here's why and his friend who he
correspondent with by mail said that's
great what did you what did you have to
do to figure this out he said oh I had
to invent integral and differential
calculus and that helped me solve this
answer we struggle with our calculus
class and Newton invented on a dare just
to get something else done and he did
this before he turned 26 I could go on
there's a story shared to me brother
c-span how you doing you end up taping
the thing there
I got to get this other quick story on
Newton this was conveyed to me by a rich
guy a friend and colleague at Princeton
where he'd spent some time in Cambridge
and learned these sort of Newton stories
apparently over the river cam there's a
cam revver as we get cam bridge
Isaac Newton designed a bridge it's not
a big river it's like a stream called a
river but it's a stream he designed a
bridge made of wood that'll eight
neighbors you to walk across the bridge
to walk across the river this bridge had
no screws or nails in it it was just
wood pieces assembled together into a
stable bridge then at some point hundred
years later people figure well maybe we
should clean the bridge for gorf Nord
polish it up so they take apart the
bridge and they can't figure out how to
put it back together so they got nails
in it now Isaac Newton also he's
responsible for the ridges on coins what
but where'd that come from well he was
so famous in his day the government had
to like reward him somehow
so they made him Chancellor of the
Exchequer so he was he he tracked
British currency make sure there was no
no counterfeiters and it was his idea to
put ridges on coins that's why today we
have ridges on our coins we wonder why
you do it's not really relevant to
anything but I did kind of lead you
there didn't I okay so the ridge is it
turns out and the old days coins used to
be raided made of like precious metal
right not today we know but back then
the coin was silver or gold so a coin
comes into your possession you'd say
nobody will notice
let me just file off with just a little
bit of the edge and collect it in a
little vessel
nobody notice then if I do this enough
times I'll have a pot of gold now you
think you're the only one thinking this
but everybody is thinking this and so
the coins just got smaller and smaller
and smaller and so he said we got to do
something about you put ridges on it
if the ridges are wiped away you decline
the coin takes a brilliant man to come
up with something that simple and so all
of our coins dime and up have ridges and
no one wants to file copper off your
penny all right there's a point we just
don't put in the ridges all right it's
like keep the penny all right I put the
whole penny in the thing no one's going
to hurt no one's going to miss it so
where was that back to intelligent
design so here's Newton so I think I
made it clear to you what I think of the
man so he solves his equations for
gravity and says okay there's it's it's
a two-body problem so he's got you
figured out Earth Moon and the orbit
figured out the Sun and the earth he's
got it he figured it out figured out the
Sun in each of the planets but then he
realized that as Earth comes around the
bend and Jupiter happens to be out there
that not only is the Sun and Earth
pulling on each other
Jupiter is tugging on earth every time
we come around to back stretch Jupiter
is tugging and I come around I go guy go
a little further cuz Jupiter went
further then I come around I get the tug
again and so he looked at this we got
the major gravity and then we have these
minor tugs and he tried his best to
figure this out he said this system is
unstable you keep this up the orbits
will get distorted out of recognition
and earth would fly off into space yet
somehow we're all still here
and somehow the orbits are pretty
circular in there so they're ellipses
but not bad ellipses so something is
keeping things stable and for the first
time in his entire record of the
discovery of the laws of mechanics and
the laws of gravity in this tome that
one of the greatest science books ever
written and it's called Principia in
that for the first time Isaac Newton
says God must step in fix
he didn't mention God talking about his
formula F equals MA
his formula for emotion he didn't talk
about God when he knew and figured out
the motions of the planets and it's
universal law God is nowhere to be found
he gets to a point where he can't answer
the question
God is there that's intelligent design
something he couldn't figure out there
it is
he didn't say maybe someone else smarter
than I who will figure this out one day
it's not what he said and so this
concept of reaching the limits of your
knowledge and then saying God is there
is all old it's not new didn't first
show up in Dover Pennsylvania and we're
not talking about uneducated people here
we're talking about some of the most
brilliant minds the world has ever
produced so so now what happened let's
fast forward it took 130 years but
somebody was finally born who could
solve that problem
Simone Pierre de Laplace a brilliant
French mathematician of the late 18th
century in the last three years of the
18th century he produced a five volume
tone called citizen mechanic or
mechanics or celestial mechanics
in English but he's French so it would
that's what it was so in there he
studies the stability of the solar
system invents a new or develops
perfects a new branch of calculus called
perturbation theory and what he says is
okay I can figure it out set up the
equation this way you've got the main
force and now you have these little tugs
represent all these little tugs by this
term in this equation now crank the
equation and when you do that it turns
out the little tugs don't amount to much
they all cancel out and so that in fact
the solar system is stable beyond
Newton's projections for it napoleon
who's a contemporary of Laplace summoned
up this
Napoleon he wasn't just a little tyrant
he studied engineering and physics said
he would know where his cannonballs
would drop okay
that's at least half the reason why he
was successful he go to his library
which which I visited it's a whole wall
just physics and engineering and and and
what's the study of materials metallurgy
and metallurgy all on the wall so he
summons up Laplace said this is a
brilliant piece of work the probably was
smart enough to read this book knew
enough math to have read this book and
gotten the main gist of it said Laplace
this is a brilliant piece of work but
you make no mention of the architect of
the system and Laplace replied sir I had
no need for that hypothesis and so here
you have a delay of one hundred and
thirty years of a problem that
previously was ascribed to the handiwork
of God now was no longer an assumption
and it gets solved by somebody who's
brilliant and so what we've learned over
all of these examples and they're tons
of them one consult is that intelligent
design is a philosophy of ignorance it
is you get to something that you don't
understand and then you stop you say god
did it and you no longer progress beyond
that point and you're going to wait
around now here's what here's that
here's what's here's what's inexcusably
hubristic about that comment you're
going to come to this point and you're
going to say I can't solve this problem
neither can anyone who will ever be born
after me solve this problem therefore it
is intelligently designed deal you make
that comment oh maybe it's true but I
don't want to put you in charge of the
like Alzheimer's research or if the
cancer prevention research no that would
put you somewhere else put you on the
factory line or something I'm going to
get you out of that frontier lab because
the discoveries are not coming from you
and so the issue in Dover should not
have been kick ID out of the school
system know it sweet people people have
invoked it you don't sweep that under
the rug it's a fascinating part of the
chapter of this is in history so put it
in the philosophy class put it in the
religion class put it in the history of
science class but because science is a
philosophy of discovery it has no place
in the science classroom and that was my
only argument it simply doesn't belong
in the science classroom because it's
not science and that essay has been
heavily downloaded I don't know what
people are doing with it but I'm happy
to have served in that capacity to at
least put it in context so the people if
you engage in the conversation you can
do it in an informed way and not in some
kind of a you know emotionally driven
irrational way in a similar case which
came after this book just a month ago to
a December mid December do you remember
this case is a Jersey kid who taped his
history teacher telling the students
that they'll burn in hell if they don't
accept Jesus as their Savior
and he said that the Big Bang and
evolution is not scientific and that
Noah's Ark carried dinosaurs and so I so
and once again plenty people arguing
that out and I said let me just let me
stay away from that but then I said know
something I gotta come back alright um
so not tell you why I came back it was
being argued on on on the you know First
Amendment separation of church and state
people say this is a violation of
separation of church and state and it
can't happen and it's public tax money
and and there was a whole Amendment
conversation going on about why this
should not have
and I'm thinking no wait wait stop stop
and I say it's not nothing to do with
the First Amendment it's got nothing to
do with legalities the ALCL ACLU it's
got nothing to do with any of these
people what it has to do with so it's
not the separation of church and state
it's that if he says the Big Bang and
evolution are not scientific and that
Noah's Ark carried dinosaurs what's
really going on here is that it's not
that you want to separate church and
state that you want to separate ignorant
scientifically illiterate people from
the ranks of teachers that's what you
need to do in that case now if he had
only said Jesus is your Savior and you
got to take him in he's it okay then
it's a religion get with the religion
somewhere else problem but if he's also
going to say that Noah carried dinosaurs
on the ark and claim that that's true I
don't care what religion that comes from
that is demonstrably false we know our
width is the museum we got dinosaur
bones in this museum we know where they
came from okay
they long predate human beings long
predate human beings by 65 million years
elapsed so I actually wrote that letter
to the New York Times and they published
it in the letter letters to the editor
second oh if you caught it but that was
like six well I was just - power - it
was just a little so I had to get that
off my chest as well that happened now
I'm gonna leave you with a thought that
I hope keeps you awake at nights and it
has to do with our assessments of
ourselves there's been a long trend in
the history of science to basically tell
us that we are not unique in any way
that one might measure any sensible way
one might measure that we thought maybe
birth was something
Niq in the known universe is not which
is another planet in orbit around a
unique star no no the Sun is just one of
hundred billion stars in a unique galaxy
no now we've got 100 billion galaxies in
our unique universe okay that's kind of
where we are now right are we sticking
with one universe or we got following
that trend say maybe there's the
multiverse we're just one of multiple
universes we've got top people working
on that now
among the things we'd like to tell us is
that we are smart as a species smartest
species there ever was and we celebrate
that fact we say we're human and they're
not we can compose poetry we we create
symphonies we sonnets and calculus and
not all of us invent the calculus but we
the least can study it okay now you know
our closest genetic relative is what
yeah chimpanzee chimpanzee and depending
how you measure it's high 90s in percent
of DNA that we share now if you ask a
chimpanzee oh excuse me what's the
Pythagorean theorem a chimpanzee is not
going to give you the right answer there
now I will give you you know how much
time you need to teach it to him he's
not going to learn the Pythagorean
theorem okay let's get simple why let's
just give it the times table it's not
going to learn the times table either
maybe up to three or maybe just up to
one long division no but we can do all
those things
so we're smart now maybe we're not so
smart now here's what that's what keeps
me awake at night this is just kind of
spooky are you ready okay
if the miniscule DNA difference between
humans and apes and other Apes or in
particular the chimpanzee
if the miniscule difference in DNA
between us accounts for this vast gulf
in intelligence then maybe that does not
represent a vast gulf in intelligence
consider consider a creature a species
with the same increment small increment
in DNA beyond us that we are beyond the
chimpanzee just a little bit give it to
them what will they be capable of look
at what we're capable of compared with
the chip now ask what would they be
capable compared to us and now think of
just one flu okay we put our toddlers in
front of Sesame Street and they learn
their ABCs they put their toddlers in
front of calculus streets and by age 4
calculus is self evidence what do we put
on our refrigerator doors we put the
pasta collages on the refrigerator doors
what would they put on the refrigerator
doors their kids come home with
symphonies composed it's all Junior just
did a you know four-part harmony 9 cards
at symphony today oh isn't that cute the
Junior did that oh so cute
our greatest intellectual achievements
would be trivial expressions of the
intellect of a creature that had that
small increment above us that we have
above chimpanzees they would show us to
their fellow species as we show
chimpanzees they might be they might
they might take special interest in
Stephen Hawking they say here's a
special one among them okay Junior
see you know the astrophysics you're
doing into kindergarten well in these
stupid humans it he's better than cuz he
can do it in his head okay
and he can do it in his head and so
they'll study him because he can do in
his head what the rest of us have to
write down or can't do it all so he be a
subject of study and so here we are
thinking we're great thinking we're at
the top of everything it's because it
feels good to to cushion ourselves that
way intellectually physically
emotionally but the fact is we may not
be much at all
and that worries me because it might
mean that there's some boundary in the
universe that in fact we're just too
stupid to figure out now our advantage
is everyone single one of us doesn't
have to be completely smart because we
we are we accumulate discoveries I don't
have to invent calculus somebody else
did I can step on top of that and then
try to increment it from there
so we're scaling this ladder rung by
rung so I'd maybe some hope for us but I
don't want to approach this with some
kind of large ego thinking we're the top
of anything that's the source of most of
the evils in the world thinking you're
at the top of something when in fact
you're not or at least at best you're
just the same and the most profound
concept that I can share with you in
this book is the recognition that while
it's humbling to recognize it but it's
humbling to see that we're not you know
we're small we're kind of feeble with
the mercy of asteroid where we're but
you know we've got two or three pounds
of grain out of here that at least
figured out the stuff that we did that's
kind of cool but not only that we know
enough about the universe to know that
it's not that simply we are here in the
universe is out there you look at the
chemical ingredients of life itself put
them in order in in rank order you get
hydrogen which comes from the water
molecule you get oxygen which comes from
the water molecule you get carbon it's
the foundation of our chemistry you get
nitrogen in order and the next one is
that
most famous element of them all it's on
every single list it's called other okay
so hydrogen oxygen carbon nitrogen other
now you got left that's enough that's in
life now let's turn to the universe and
say hey universe what do you have ranked
among your elements what's number one
for you hydrogen what's number two
helium well if you remember from
chemistry class helium is inert you
couldn't do anything with it chemically
even if you tried so let's skip that
next in the universe oxygen carbon
nitrogen other thank you so we are one
for one the same ingredients in the
universe which itself is a bit humbling
if we were made of an isotope of bismuth
then you'd have an argument say hey
we're rare stuff come here check us out
look at where we are all right and but
like no no we're made of the most common
ingredients of the universe but those
ingredients are traceable to the actions
of high mass stars that forge these
elements in their core destabilize
exploded spread their enriched
ingredients their guts across the galaxy
creating environments where the next
generation of stars will have the
ingredients that can then make planets
and people and so not only are we in
this universe the universe is in us and
I know of no more enlightening in nobly
enriching thought than that and that is
a thought I'll leave you with this
evening thank you for your attention
uh we can we can hang out for questions
and and but some people have to go so I
don't want to stop that like if you park
too far away or you like live in Jersey
or something but but but you can hang
out I mean how often can you hang out
Plusle and astrophysics being that
one-in-a-million thing here's the big
chance okay so you should wait until the
microphone comes to you otherwise no one
in c-span land will know what you ask
okay so when we come right here to the
gentleman on the aisle test test
right there test test you guys here yeah
you're on you're on okay sir yes Neil I
wanted to ask when the c-span program
would be but before that I have to ask
does the Hayden Planetarium pay you
enough to buy a pair of pants that isn't
it
oh oh the question was is my salary
sufficient to buy pants that do not rip
this rip happened two hours ago and I
don't normally bring spare pants to my
office that would not look good to carry
extra pants into your office and so I
had so I had to ask myself what do I do
about this fact then I realized it's
like fashion you know people pay top
dollar for cut up pants so what I did
was I swear to you it looked too clean I
said if it's that clean people think I'm
just stupid and didn't like know that I
had a rip in my pants so I pulled the
threads off so that it looks like they
were bought this way and now I look here
okay but that was not my point okay
I meant no disrespect by wearing holey
pants here tonight um it happened just a
few hours ago to my dismay okay and I
have no idea when they will air the
c-span program but I'll give you the
mantra check your local listings as they
say okay sir on the corner here yes and
we'll give her a good workout in fact
while I'm answering I'll try to pick the
next one so that you can stay in shape
there yes hello what did James Cameron
give you a special effects credit for
for the news oh no no no he did but he
did give me a free copy of the of the
new release by actually I'm a servant of
public appetite I don't need I don't
look for credit um could could actually
could anything survive a black hole what
a bacteria be spaghettified and also
theoretically possible to build a ship
that was a ship that can go through a
black hole and how would that be done of
have you ever thought about that the
answer to your first three questions is
no have I thought about it yes
a bacterium will last much longer than
you will because it's smaller and the
difference in force of gravity across a
bacterium is is much smaller than it
would be for a human so we'd have to get
much closer before it would then become
spaghettified but it is it is a
spaghettify oisin it's you won't survive
it no matter what on the way to the
center of the black hole you want to
take in a ship that would be the last
thing you'd ever did and don't expect to
phone home when you get to where you're
going no the ship is gone the ship
shares the same space as your
spaghettified atoms at the center of the
black hole so have a nice day another
two-seater alright right here on the
second row in orange orange dude thank
you
you intimated the end that when you
don't know something maybe you could
speculate a little bit
I wonder if you mind speculating about
black holes a hole can be like a well
with a bottom to it for a hole make it
be something that goes through something
if you speculated that maybe
the universe and you intimated that that
that might be a small distance so
wouldn't be at the end of our universe
it would probably be somewhere in it
how would you speculate might be within
a black hole what do you think about
that possibility other possibilities
did anyone hear that question yeah just
question is how can I speculate about
what's going on inside a black hole does
it I'm going to paraphrase you a little
bit is it a tunnel to somewhere else can
we just dream up stuff that might happen
inside of a black hole our laws of
physics are pretty clear on this one
there's the spaghetti equation that your
spaghetti there's no way around that now
it was once imagined that a black hole
would be a portal to another part of the
universe and maybe you'd enter and sort
of come out the other side before you
hit the center because the real
spaghettification happens if you're
aiming for the center of the black hole
but Stephen Hawking just recently came
out with a result that tells us that the
black hole is not a portal to somewhere
else because it remembers everything at
eight you know as you may remember a
black holes evaporate
it's called Hawking radiations what made
him famous beyond his normal circles
back in the 1970s he recognized that the
energy field the gravity field of a
black hole could could spontaneously
create particles just outside the event
horizon this is the boundary between the
point of no return and the point of
return it could spontaneously create
particles there that would escape and so
these are particles healing forth from
the energy field of its gravity
what Hawking showed is that if I drop
you in and we take an inventory of all
the atoms that went in from your body
all the quarks protons electrons let's
inventory it and then I wait a hundred
billion years and I look at the slow
evaporation that comes out I will
reconstruct the entire inventory of
particles that went in body and soul
when they first hundred billion years
earlier so the gravity field remembers
the property of the matter that went in
and the for that to Beach
it means the information was not lost it
means the information didn't go
somewhere else and leave town and show
up on the other side of the universe and
while this was disturbing to science
fiction writers because they needed this
as a vehicle to get around the galaxy
especially before the TV commercial ends
to get across the galaxy
would otherwise take to a hundred
thousand years Star check would be
boring track you know without the warp
drive so but I celebrated it as this
amazing spooky thing that black holes
remember what they eat even through the
slow process of Hawking evaporation if a
black hole eats it's going to get bigger
but if there's nothing around for you to
eat it'll just kind of hang there and
that it will just slowly evaporate they
evaporate very slowly by this Hawking
mechanism most of them are eating faster
than they're evaporating let's go right
here front row this is question about
intelligent design I don't believe in it
but don't you think there's some force
like a dire force in the universe that
makes the different shapes of the
galaxies elliptical etc instead of just
chaotic forms something something going
on she suspects that there might be
something going on in the universe
because the level of I'm paraphrasing
the level of order that you see with the
beautiful spiral galaxies an elliptical
their shapes that that that look like
something that's going on there some
larger sort of cosmic force and what you
must not have seen the galaxies that
have collided and look like two train
wrecks
let's not have seen those or the class
of galaxies we call irregular galaxies
that have no shape that you would point
to so you are pre-editing what you are
so you're pre-selecting things and say
oh look there's some interesting force
going on there when the rest of the
universe is sitting there raggedy and
you're not commenting on that so what
I'm saying is the moment you think
something's beautiful in renard just
take another look
taken I remember I remember I was there
we were coming over a bridge with a
friend and he saw the sunset and the
braid Ian
raise and he saw those beautiful God's
talking to me that's God and I said
because it's beautiful
is that why you say that anything yeah
it's just and I said well do you think
about God when you get a close-up view
of the underbelly of a tarantula are you
thinking Oh beautiful no you're not
right this is the same universe
these and so so so if you're selective
about the list you draw then the
universe could look like any philosophy
you want it to look like but once you
take it all in you realize that the
universe wants to kill us 99% of all the
species that have ever lived are now
extinct earth is not some cradle for
life it is a place that wants to kill us
viruses asteroid earthquakes tsunamis
volcanoes and so we're running away from
these things and we find a little place
that we think is safe then the flood
comes and then you know and then okay
now we finally got a place now the
temperature drops we got to like put on
clothing and they'd get heat and oh now
always an earth so beautiful for us it's
like no no so so I would just be
cautious about that I know that I
understand the urge but I understand and
on top of that there are forces that
make things round in the universe
in fact I invite you I didn't make it to
this book as much as I'd like the essay
it actually didn't make the cut to this
I wrote an essay called on being round
and I talked about spiral galaxies and
elliptical galaxies in it so just Google
Tyson on being round they'll take you
right there there's a whole conversation
of why things around it neither and yes
it is a force but it's not some
mysterious Gaia thing we don't
understand we understand it is real and
we can calculate it but there's certain
laws of physics that the universe
follows um I would I would I would
rather reword that statement to say
there are laws of physics that describe
the universe because the universe could
care less about what we think of it the
universe is not obeying our laws of
physics so but yes that's correct there
are laws of physics out there people who
say that the laws of physics is the
expression of God
and if you want to say that I don't
nothing I can't nothing I can find
in fact that's very close to Spinoza's
gods but noses God was the whatever you
find to be the order of the universe
that is the expression of God and that's
a very different God from the God who's
listening to prayers and and then that
sort of thing or you know or puts
dinosaurs on arks that's it these are
different kinds of gods okay and so so
the so that would be closer to Spinoza's
God but be cautious there because in the
days when no one understood what was
going on in the heavens that was used as
evidence that it was the handiwork of
God because why would you ever
understand God what God did the fact
that you didn't understand it was this
was the citation of God at work so now
to say we do understand it there are
laws and also claim that that is the
handiwork of God that is writing both
sides of that horse and so I don't have
a problem with it but one needs to be
aware of this philosophical trend where
God is what you don't know and God is
what you do know so God is everything
and and if that then I'd ask is fine but
is that going to help me make my next
scientific discovery if not I'm going to
put it over here and bring in the books
that will ah why don't you pick now cuz
that way you can run around alright
we're going to take just about two more
because we're really at a time I mean I
did like I tell kids in this room I
wanted like to get a kid question but
yes so let's see kid here okay how long
ago was the big bang by the way how old
are you by the way you're eight years
old thank you
how long ago was the Big Bang we looked
at how fast the universe is expanding
and then we said okay let's turn the
clock backwards and we watched the
universe claps back and when you do that
you find out that the whole universe was
in the same place at the same time
fourteen billion years ago so that's how
long ago it was long before the
beginning of Earth and our solar system
and our galaxy so what kind of
johnny-come-lately
on this another kid question right here
yes exactly our I exactly will power
black lows forms our black holes for
excellent question
we have no idea how you make the big
ones in the Centers of galaxies so we
got top people working on that one but
the ones that are just kind of laying
around the neighborhood those are the
those are there remnants of the death of
high mass stars some of the stars that
explode to spread their guts they will
need supernovas they will leave behind
their they will sir they will live they
will leave behind they'll leave to the
side in some cases a neutron star a star
pack of neutral Neutron but it has more
mass than a particular threshold that
will further collapse to a black hole
yes Clint collapse
time and space yes and if that star that
now black hole is not near another star
you could accidentally step in it and
not know that it was there unless you
look carefully at what it did to the
light from stars behind it because it
distorts the fabric of space and time
and you start seeing weird patterns of
the light behind it as though you drag
the lens across you're a funhouse lens
across the field of view so you need
special funhouse lens watchers on
spaceships okay because if you don't
catch this early enough it would be
worse than not catching the iceberg on
the Titanic okay
but sometimes they're near other stars
and then you can see the the the
secondary star getting dined upon and
then you know to sort of step around
that situation oh I heard someone say
asteroid is there an asteroid in the
house are you just worried you just
don't want to go extinct is that is
that's your problem here okay there is
an asteroid discovered third week of
December 2004
okay so is discovered and they got they
look for data from before and after they
got enough data to then calculate this
just took about a week to calculate that
this asteroid will come extremely close
to Earth extremely close so the same
when we got some really impatient people
here who wanna like hit the go for the
hills when this they have it so here
goes right so they named it once they
saw where was headed they named it they
called it Apophis after the Egyptian god
of death and darkness we did not name
that one Bambi so it is the size of the
Rose Bowl so take a rock fill the entire
volume of the Rose Bowl with it that's
how big this thing is
it is hurtling through space depending
on the angle you look at it 1015 miles
per second is it speed relative to us
then they figure out well how close is
it going to get they run it through the
computer they find out that on Friday
the 13th in April in the year 2029
Apophis will come close enough to earth
to dip below our orbiting communication
satellites it will be the biggest
closest thing ever observed in cultural
history now if you want to observe that
you go to northern Europe get your hotel
rooms now and that puppy will go
straight on by now that's just the
entertaining part it turns out the orbit
is uncertain enough such that we can't
tell you exactly how close we know it's
closer than the orbiting satellites but
within that uncertainty we can't tell
you we don't know it yet because this
thing is tumbling through space it's
hard to get the exact orbital parameters
but there is a window of orbits within
the total range it can have which if it
goes
through that keyhole the gravity of
Earth is just right or rather just wrong
so that seven years later once again on
April 15th April not tax day April 13th
it will hit earth if it goes through
that keyhole it will hit Earth and if it
goes through the senator keyhole we know
where it's going to hit on earth five
hundred kilometers west of Santa Monica
it will plunge into the Pacific Ocean go
down a depth of about three miles and
then explode cavitating the Pacific
gotta watch my pant ripping there
cavitate the Pacific to make a hole
three miles wide and three miles deep
oceans don't like having holes in them
okay so the act of making this hole
sends a first pulse all across the
Pacific and there it is in motion
then the walls collapse down in it
sloshes back into itself rises high into
the atmosphere and comes back down
cavitating the ocean again and this
rhythm will repeat dozens of times and
each time this repeats a pulse a tsunami
wave heads towards the shores now unlike
the Indonesian tsunami by the way you
didn't hear about Apophis when it was
discovered because it was its orbit was
calculated the same week as the
Indonesian tsunami that's why you didn't
hear about this we knew all of this for
two years now we knew it but justifiably
it was it was put in the back behind the
Indonesian tsunami but this tsunami make
the Indonesian salami look like somebody
just stepped into a puddle the in
unlikely the Indonesian tsunami which
just went smoothly into the Shores
unrelentingly this tsunami will come to
the shores but then cycle back to get
ready for the next pulse and again and
again so what will happen is the tsunami
comes to the shoreline it grabs the
homes that were there and then pulls it
out okay
then up time to go back to shore it's an
outcomes back now the house has a
different shape okay the house is no
longer a box it is a tangled mess
of construction materials and so now it
comes back and it churns away all
evidence of civilization on the entire
west coast of the United States
basically sandblasting it clean of all
traces of civilization I'll have about
fifty feet high so five stories high now
there will be stupid people like surfers
who want to say let me get that wave
coming in they will be stupid
meteorologists here comes the wave right
here that can't get the camera right
here can you see you know these people
exist right the the Hurricanes coming
down on the Florida coast and they got
somebody there you know and meme up the
camera is trying to back up you know
away from the thing while the reporter
is reporting on the waves of the
crashing on their you know there'll be
people who want to do this but in
principle nobody has to die because we
can predict when this will happen now
better than predicting when it will
happen and telling everyone run for the
hills I'd rather actually do something
about it in the first place like deflect
it
hey what an idea that we got top people
working on this one you take a spaceship
bring it if this is the asteroid and
bring it up next to the asteroid here's
a spaceship and then it'll want to fall
towards it they have mutual gravity but
you put in a little retro rockets to
prevent it from falling in if you do
this early enough you can actually
gravitation gravitationally tugged the
asteroid out of harm's way because the
act of preventing the spaceship from
falling is tantamount to pulling the
asteroid in your direction and all you
have to do is pull it out of the keyhole
it'll still come by and you'll have to
keep an eye on it later on
but if it's out of the keyhole we're
safe which brings up a whole other set
of problems suppose you try to get it
out of the keyhole and you miss and then
it goes to a different part of the
keyhole and then lands and hits another
country had you never touched it
insurance forms would have called that
an act of God
but now that you touched it what do you
call it what is that it's an active war
right so this is Connie you know this is
an unresolved political cultural problem
and suppose it's headed for for the
Indian Ocean obviously we're going to
want to care about it if it's headed for
the Pacific because we're directly
affected by it with the most expensive
real estate facing the tsunamis but
suppose it's somewhere else
who pays for it there's no mechanism
that exists right now to resolve how to
handle that problem there's no
international mechanism we've got people
working on it one of them is a friend
and colleague rusty Schweickart who's
got a website the b612 foundation is
check it out org beasts the numeral six
numeral one numeral two that happens to
be the name of what that is the asteroid
that the little prince landed on alright
make you the asteroid will make us
extinct
so it's not that cute um so anyhow we
would survive that's not that's not a
species extinct thing asteroid Apophis
is not it would just do a lot of
property damage and so even if it did
hit but it would be a bad day on earth
and be the worst natural disaster ever
but again nobody has to die
and so now I now I just totally bummed
you out you know but anyhow the universe
is a fun place and and thank you for all
just coming to hear me talk about by the
way I just learned I just learned so I
was very I just learned a couple of days
ago that this coming weekend this is
just eat onto the New York Times
bestseller list I didn't know I didn't I
now I don't know how long it'll stay
there you know who knows if a next Harry
Potter book will come in and bump it out
who knows what's that one way and I've
never been there before it's a very good
feeling and it's only there because of
support from you guys and others of your
passion for hearing about what we do as
astrophysicist thank you for coming I'll
be outside to sign books thank you
Neil deGrasse Tyson is author of origins
fourteen billion years of cosmic
evolution the sky is not the limit
Adventures of an urban astrophysicist
and his latest death by black hole and
other cosmic quandary director of the
Hayden Planetarium at the American
Museum of Natural History you can learn
more about Neil deGrasse Tyson at a m
and H org